the joe rogan experience and uh rachel's
fantastic she's so good she's right and
she's a lovely person like can you
imagine she must be yeah they're always
that good an actor
i don't know some people might be they
might be hollywood's full of a lot of
interesting deceit too bro i know it is
yeah yeah and sometimes we get to watch
it on trial
um oh yeah oh my gosh
that they had a relationship trial
like this is who was more [ __ ] up in
the relationship yeah let's show the
whole world yeah yeah i don't know how i
feel about i like there's a part of me
that just wishes that nobody would
really care about any of that drama as
it unfolds because it's not pertinent to
anybody's life really or making the
world a better place like
who gets paid for the advertising money
from that trial
there must have been a lot of it um who
gets the does johnny's cut of the
youtube time was it all youtube i don't
know i mean but a lot of it is available
on youtube i mean where was it available
for free when it came out how did they
the people making the videos or making
money i feel like i saw an article that
said someone's making like 60 grand a
month making
reaction videos to the trial or
something just reaction videos of the
trial or showing it or highlights
everybody wants to know what everybody
else thinks about it that the trial is a
perfect thing to have a reaction video
because there's so many moments in that
certainly certainly but i think things
like that though
ultimately they're i don't know man it i
i feel like it's making us
less empathetic ultimately it is it is
making we all get to look at these
people literally you know like you're
saying like that they're having a
a marital dispute we're all getting
brought in on their non nonsense their
their [ __ ] their traumas all that stuff
and everyone just gets to sit around
eating popcorn and judging the entire
fiasco because it's entertainment now
it's like everything is content and
everything is entertainment but the more
we do that kind of stuff i do feel like
we're pulling farther apart from being
able to look at either her or him and
say
you both have issues and you both need
to work on some [ __ ] and you know
however the the jury and all that that
found it i ultimately i saw little bits
and pieces it seemed like he was more in
the right than she was i would have gone
with that too but the point is they're
still human beings both of them the end
of the day and they're just a circus
when when we see it like that seemingly
i think he wanted the circus because the
circus exposes the truth i think that
was the only way to expose the truth but
to get her to talk about stuff on camera
and he felt like
she would kind of fall apart certainly
but i don't think that
that could have been done just in the
courtroom without it airing to the rest
of the world
all that stuff would have been said on
on some cameras that are recording in
that room and why are we trying to
pretend the jury didn't know how the
rest of the world felt
i know it's something in that case it's
so ridiculous in that case how do you
keep jurors away from anything how do
you keep them away from their phones
yeah i don't know i don't know i i don't
know
like do we give up on that on jurors
being influenced by the outside world no
i'm that's still very much the law i
believe but wasn't it at a certain point
in time that they were restricted like
they weren't allowed to watch media or
something like that they were
sequestered yeah i mean is that still
going on or do they get to go home it
depends on the trial i think so yeah
like in the o.j simpson trial all those
guys got sequestered for a long [ __ ]
time oh man it was not
not ideal for any of them and after all
that they still come up with a [ __ ] up
verdict
i mean
it was a that was i i agree i don't i
don't see
him as being innocent in that at all but
you know rodney king had just gotten
beaten on a freeway and there was a lot
of anger and a lot of
pain and frustration and again not that
that should
make the other right or whatever but
it's still just i think we got to come
back and be like
you know i don't know
we're human you're right
like everyone who's mocking the trial me
included is not being empathetic to the
fact that these are two human beings but
there's something about liars in
particular that people when they're
lying and they are doing it to try to
damage someone else yeah oh it's
horrible it's one of them the creepiest
so there's there's a certain amount of
signaling that everybody's doing by not
being empathetic because it is such a
public thing a certain amount of
signaling that we're doing to each other
saying hey that is [ __ ] [ __ ]
always and everybody kind of agrees and
then it's it's kind of better for people
it's better for people to see that on
display and see people's reaction to it
and make people think about what is it
like if someone lies about something
just to try to damage someone yeah well
listen i 100 believe that all lies
should be exposed that you know sunlight
is the best disinfectant we should be
able to talk about all that [ __ ] for
sure
um but i think yeah hopefully it can be
done where
we all get the example but we're still
nice to each other but we're yeah
we're still radically loving each other
yeah
it's possible yeah it is possible
it is it's possible for people to be way
nicer to each other
you